you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome my name is Holly and I'm the UK
head of communication here at CD Projekt
RED and I will be your host for today as
we take a deep dive into cyberpunk 2077
we're gonna be showing you a video with
new gameplay and new gameplay mechanics
and afterwards I'll be joined by three
of our developers Myles Phillip and
Pavel as we take a closer look at some
of the things you're going to see and
hopefully answer some of your questions
on behalf of everybody at CD Projekt RED
we're incredibly excited to share this
new look at cyberpunk 2077 with you
avy you alright let's do this
you know about what is it
[Applause]
[Music]
what now
[Applause]
jomi
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
where are we el bebé is that a fortress
Britt's to the deep net
[Music]
beyond
[Applause]
welcome to the cyberpunk 2077 2019 deep
dive video in last year's gameplay
review we showed you our vision for the
world of cyberpunk 2077 its quests and
visual design this environment we'd like
to give you a peek at some of the play
styles you'll be able to adopt as your
character progresses through the story
it was nothing you're about to see
sequences embodying two distinct
approaches to playing cyber will show
you a strong solo build that is a
character who focuses on employing blunt
force and taking instant action
and a netrunner booth a play style
taking frequent advantage of stealth
tactics packing and battlefield control
achieved using malicious software
additionally you'll learn more about
Pacifica one of the games districts two
gangs and the animals and the Rue du
Bois and you'll see glimpses of Johnny
silver the digital construct who Hans
our main character
[Music]
a word of caution given that the video
covers a section of the game deep into
the main storyline we have edited the
footage to contain as few spoilers as
possible be aware that the gameplay as
presented does reveal characters and
locations you'll see while playing the
game's main story our so watch at your
own discretion
where we headed
be sweet
in this video you'll experience a
segment of a quest from the middle of
the game we're currently in Pacific one
of night cities six unique districts no
busing McCollum
you guys aren't exactly great of rolling
out the welcome mat for outside it was
designed to be a tourist hotspot within
the city as you can see this didn't pan
out
when uncertainty struck the global
economy investors pulled their funding
leaving most establishments unfinished
it's one of those places where
expectations and reality collide
resulting in a heap of disappointing
ongoing gang wars plagued this part of
the city Outsiders don't come here if
they don't have to even by night city
standards
it's dangerous to those unfamiliar
taking a casual stroll here would not be
a good idea a fast motorbike or
armor-plated car would be the safer
option
but places like this have their
advantages if you're in need of rare
goods or illegal cyberware Pacifica's
bustling local markets are a good place
to start your search the grand imperial
mall is a whole other story it was one
of the last developments in Pacifica to
lose its funding until recently it stood
vacant but now again called the animals
has moved in for reasons unknown and
that's what we need to learn in order to
earn the trust of the Rue du Bois the
animals rivals what the hell could
[ __ ] tell me what you plan to do
first you take jump you do what I see of
the many gangs in cyberpunk 2077 the
Voodoo boys are the most skilled at
using the net why what for this
mysterious gang of highly skilled net
runners has close ties to the local
Haitian community you are
been waiting patients settled in
Pacifica in the 2060s after natural
disasters struck their Idol and forced
them to emigrate on mass the voodoo boys
gang formed around this same time though
at a smaller scale now the gang
effectively rules Pacifica
voodoo boys don't usually work with
outsiders lucky for us it seems they're
prepared to make an exception this time
mr. Hanson said you got Murph work needs
doing still to earn their trust we need
to prove our worth plac'd one of the
voodoo boys higher-ups has offered a
submission we need to infiltrate the
grand Imperial mall currently occupied
by the Voodoo boys deadly enemy a gang
called the animals
20850 civic 3-second before become your
net we try to learn where they come your
net come from the animals are not your
normal game their presence and Pacifica
is suspicious the value might above all
else and where melee combat implants to
raise their prowess in combat their
beverage of choices juice opponents
strength and speed enhancing concoction
as sought-after bouncers they're usually
dispersed throughout town as skilled
street-level business types they've
cornered the market in illegal
substances and underground live or die
prize fights when they converge in one
spot it's for something big it's then
they appoint the fastest and strongest
among as their ad-hoc leader in this
case it's a woman named sasquatch
break up the coffee bit this is the tech
plac'd was talking about it seems
non-standard for the animals and this is
where we come in getting to the van
won't be easy but we're more than
qualified for the job which we can
complete in one of many ways
the character creation in cyberpunk 2077
is the kind you'd expect from a
full-fledged RPG you start by choosing
your past important because this unlocks
special options at important story
junctures you also fully customize your
character using a deep customization
system that spans not only your look and
style but also your abilities cyberpunk
2077 does not feature fixed classes
instead it has a fluid class system that
allows players to mix and match a wide
range of abilities to suit their play
styles you can create a strong solo
character a skilled net runner or any
other hybrid class you can imagine
[Applause]
let's see how a solo play style in
cyberpunk 2077 might work solos prefer a
direct approach they use guns and might
to get these diamonds
so let's reach sematic with our enhanced
strength we can strip this turret of its
weapon to give the animals a taste of
their own medicine this is how a player
investing in solo abilities might live
out their Terminator power fantasy
enhance strength lets us force open
doors
or grab enemies to use as human shields
we also gain access to powerful melee
combat cyber lair so even someone as
fast and strong as sasquatch the leader
of this group of animals is not
impossible to beat for a solo sasquatch
has a different game plan she's out to
Jack in and haggis let's see how this
plays out what's going on
it's our choice if we want to finish her
off or spare her your cyberpunk your
rules
if you'd rather sneak around hide and
strike from the shadows no problem just
develop your net running skills to get
around obstacles or hack into enemy tech
to have it do the dirty work for you
[Music]
med running abilities mean hacking
skills that let us use our cyber deck to
breach access points for this we fill
the buffer of our cyber deck with a
string of instructions represented by
these letters and numbers matching the
instructions for basic access grants us
control of devices connected to this
network the more instructions we match
the more control we gain / elements in
the network we can hack our way through
in numerous ways a quick hack may grant
us control of the security camera
another one should let us tweak the
difficulty of the training bot to create
a distraction
[Music]
with our nanowire we can even hack this
guy's implants from a distance
[Music]
in this world almost everything is
connected to a local network
and that means it can be hacked which
brings us back to cyberspace you don't
get to do anything in the net unnoticed
there's always someone watching it could
be coor pose or even worse it could be
net watch and that is exactly the case
here net watch and the voodoo boys are
like fire and ice the first of these
wants to maintain the old order and
protect people from AI anarchy
originating from beyond the black wall
the voodoo boys want to establish
contact with the free ai's they believe
this will enable their boundless
expansion on the net and grant them the
upper hand over net watch net watch sees
this as the end of the world both are
right whoa hey how you deal with the net
watch agent is entirely up to you do we
side with the gang choosing to be on
that watch his bad side is never wise
but can we really trust the Voodoo boys
as you can see we have many possible
options but in each case we take a risk
think I'll just stick to my food
[Music]
[Music]
didn't work out well in the world of
cyberpunk few things go as planned
and that was just a glimpse of how
complex the branching storyline in
cyberpunk 2077 can get every decision
you make will have consequences your
choices will shape how the world reacts
to you and affect your relationships
with those around you one of those
relationships is special I've ever heard
of Johnny silver had a rebel rocker boy
who will be your companion throughout
your adventure in night city come on
really think they'd give a rat's dick
how you look like everyone in cyberpunk
2077
he has his own agenda you'll decide if
he'll be your ally or your enemy and
that chip in your head the one thanks to
its Johnny lives inside your mind well
that's a story for another time
[Applause]
welcome back now following the Deep
Diver is an awful lot to talk about so I
found three of the very vast but I think
just in case people aren't super
familiar with cyberpunk 2077 why don't
you introduce yourself one by one so
everybody knows who this here listening
to hey I'm miles I'm one of the level
designers at CD Projekt RED hello I'm
Paulo and I'm a lead of the questing and
it's a great pleasure to be talking to
you
so I'm Philip and I'm one of their quest
designers so I work really closely with
Pavel over here thank you guys for being
my face I mean my participation video
let's get started because the last 10
where we saw took place in Watson this
time we're in Pacifica they're very
different and that's super important for
Knight City that it feels different so
what do you need to consider as a level
designer when you're building a place
like this right we are diving right into
it so from a level design point of view
first it's really important to create
these districts is-6 ones that we have
in that city to be as different as
possible without making it unbelievable
right and we sort of orient ourselves
around sort of how we approached and say
Skelly gear and novigrad normal sound in
the witcher 3 so we're sort of aiming
for a very noticeable difference and
this has multiple purposes right first
off we want to enhance variety in the
game right would be kind of boring just
to have a lot of the same throughout the
entire city we have one city scape so we
need to create this kind of variety and
that's actually a really fun creative
process as well and secondly we need it
as a navigational tool that means that
when you as a player move around the
city you should know where you are
simply by looking around and thankfully
there's a lot of lore that we can sort
of dissect and make
that helps us around but we also add our
own sort of twists to the whole thing
right so in terms of Pacifica we know
that it's pretty pretty [ __ ] up place
if I can say so and in what I mean with
that is that it's pretty notable that is
almost post-apocalyptic right the
district has a rich history that caused
it to basically fall into disarray after
it was initially meant to become the
city's crown jewel off of tourism but
clearly as you can see from the footage
that actually didn't quite work out that
way and now you actually see things like
burning cars on the streets right and
it's very deserted so much unlike Watson
that we showed last year where the
streets are bustling with people here
there's way less because it's simply a
very dangerous place that you don't want
to really go if you don't have to and
again that's one of these things that
once you enter the district from the
rest of night City you'll actually
notice that right and of course all the
destruction going on and all of the yeah
I mean suffering and pain so what kind
of things are exclusive to Pacifica
because you don't want people to just
come for the class and then leave and
that's it you want people to keep coming
back to its district so what can people
find there I mean this is what I meant
when I said like it's a very fun process
the thing of these kind of things
because these sort of characteristics
that we give the district directly sort
of birth the things that you can find
there right and amongst the destruction
you'll still find people living there
right
Pacifica doesn't have buyer large
Haitian community and each district sort
of has
a kind of dominant gang who has taken
over there and the case of Pacifica that
would be the voodoo boys and unlike the
Maelstrom errs that we saw last year the
voodoo boys are actually deeply
ingrained within the community that
lives there and they actually there
they're not your typical sort of street
gang in the sense that they don't really
bring a lot of gun power to find
themselves but they actually specialize
in cyberspace they're obsessed with the
mysteries of cyberspace they've sort of
almost made it their own religion if you
will and they have the reputation of
being the best net runners that you can
find in night city and it's a very cool
gang that v of course our main
protagonist will interact with in
several ways how you will have to find
out and I mean that's just one of many
many different ways you'll really
experience Pacific as I said all these
things together the culture the the
visuals the architecture and the the
history really will have will have will
be very distinct to the district at the
same time we're of course trying really
hard to not make it feel disconnected
right there's always a link it should
always be believable that's one of the
sort of core pillars that we build
everything on but this will make it for
a very unique experience when you delve
in adventure in this district compared
to others and when looking at the
stories that we'll be telling in this
exact district you always make sure that
always fits to the environment to what
we want to build so you know the street
stories to do find their side quests in
the main quest that is actually placed
there it always tells the story of the
community of the people of the
characters that are living there and the
patient community right today they
arrived actually in night city because
of the environmental changes that were
happening in the world
Haiti is actually completely flooded and
they have left that they came arrive to
night city to build at the district that
miles just talked about and they were
left out at the moment when the
corporation's withdrawn
founding from the Pacifica they were
left there and they build their own
community there and they gave them the
deceit they become the seed for all the
stories that we're telling there so as a
player when you're like investing
meeting all those characters and talking
to them you actually find out and learn
more about them you know through the
quests have it but let's talk about the
more we just saw in the deep dive video
because that's not linear you've got the
building you're thinking right well the
person who's playing on their game they
might have a more techie style of play
for you but this person might want to go
in all guns blazing how do you design
levels for all these different place
that's anything's possible yes yeah we
do give the player a lot of different
tools to use as he goes through a level
and that makes designing these things
quite complex but you know just to sort
of understand our mentality and I can
actually attempt maybe you'll help me
out with this one to go back in our
development well sometime and to really
sort of we came up with this example to
sort of establish this kind of mentality
that we wanted to have when we
approached our level designs in the way
we do our encounters right and the
example was rather simple the goal was
for a player to like to go from one room
to another but the the main way to go
from that one room to another would be
sort of like a door and be it through
like a scan or device it doesn't really
matter for the example actually going
through the store would ultimately
result in the player losing his weapons
but the task was to actually kill a
person on the other side of that door
right now we use this sort of example to
sit down and think okay what how will we
do this in all these kind of different
playstyles right so perhaps you know one
way would be to you know convince a god
that would be stationed next to the door
just let you through right
through like sort of like a social kind
of path or you could take the guy out
take I don't know like a pass that would
enable you to go through the door
without actually letting go of your gun
maybe if you are invested as a melee
character actually doesn't really matter
to you you just walk through the door
and then punch the guy on the other hand
side into like a pile of blood or maybe
as a kind of hacker type of character
you try to find a way to breach the
network to disable the device right the
scanner that would prevent your weapons
were using usage allowing you to move
through and then use your guns on
whatever your target is maybe as a kind
of fast solo kind of character you'd be
able to jump out of the window onto
windowsill double jump to the you know
like a balcony and then enter through
the window there and the list goes on
and on with examples that we try to come
up for this kind of door and this sort
of again it's just to showcase how we
sort of think about these levels right
as as you know putting in a problem that
the player has to solve and we give them
a lot of different tools and
possibilities to solve this issue or
bypass it in their own way and that is
how we're hoping to really create an
experience for the player that they feel
inherently is their own right they came
up with a solution given the systems
that we gave them and and they really
get to feel like the badass cyberpunk V
that we want them to feel like it's
actually also a lot of fun to work on
this from a story perspective because
you know as an example in the Wild Hunt
we were already working with very
nonlinear stories but now we also have
this nonlinear gameplay approach and for
us it was always really important to
have these choices and consequences and
we did them in the story you know
anything should matter somehow but now
we can also say okay players have all of
these different choices to solve a
situation so of course there should also
sometimes be some consequences and
that's just on the gameplay side how you
solve it but of course you know the
story should react to it do I just run
into this room and kill a few guys or do
I you know choose a super different
approach sometimes this can open up a
completely new way
to go through a quest so you know
actually I think it added to this whole
layer of non-linearity it'll quite a few
let's say more things we have to do but
the thing is it is a challenge for us
but it's actually a really fun challenge
it's actually really cool to have to
come up with all these ideas and the
thing is also our quests are iterated
upon a lot so there's an example in our
quest designers of course we play them
ourselves
Pavel as our Lee plays them again
directors play them and also you know
most importantly QA plays our quests a
lot and our QA team has really really
good ideas so you know they always think
okay what do I think right now what
would I want to do in this situation and
then we often communicate and this is
how some of the best ideas are actually
created just through going through these
missions over and over again and always
finding some new ways to approach them
and some new ways to you know find
interesting consequences what to happen
afterwards
yeah and that I think sort of ties up
with a whole philosophy of a game which
is the freedom and we have a freedom on
a story layer and maybe I don't want to
talk about it too much and it'll spoil
it but it but it ties up with the
gameplay very well with like the way how
the levels are constructed and we're
branching in place Phillip just
explained because player has freedom
playing the game you build your
character the way you want and you play
the way and you want and you want the
player to feel this choice you know that
he's doing depending of you know how
skills he's assigning what weapons he or
she is picking and all that and it all
comes together as like you know
fulfilling this ultimate like cyberpunk
fantasy so in the demo we obviously saw
the bike there was a little mention of
the heavy armored car but can you tell
us a little bit more about the kinds of
vehicles that will be in five advanced
2015 seven I can tell you a little bit
about it there's of course many
different kinds of vehicles because we
want to create a real open city of you
know city that makes sense in the Year
2077 so there will be all kinds of
vehicles and of course there's also you
know society is very different so you
know we also have different art styles
that correspond with the different parts
of society so we have the art style
called entropy so as an example you
might see vehicles that are just very
useful they're made to just bring a
person from
to be or you know they're made to do a
job and of course but you know the
player can choose to have them as well
especially if you know player might not
have that much money yet but there's
also you know super luxury high-end
vehicles on the other side of the coin
so of course you know you as a player
are only limited by what you can afford
that's like real life yeah life is like
what we strive for but yeah you know we
try to strive for variety so you know we
also look like what are the kinds of
vehicles players would wants to have in
a cyberpunk game so you know we don't
just have cars you of course also have
bikes like our very own a guy back
kusanagi here one of my favorites it's a
very very cool bike and there's some
let's say surprise vehicles that are
still to be seen in cyberpunk and I
don't want to spoil here but I would say
something are very special that's also
dear to my heart now I really enjoyed
but of course also let's say the super
highest echelons of people in that city
they also have access to a V so flying
cars which is something that you as a
player you're not part of that world but
through specific story moments you might
get to you know ride in them sometimes
so you know we want to give you a few
different experiences but yeah you can
also of course you know you have your
garage where your apartment is so you
can also have your own vehicle that you
store that you can call to yourself so
you know you can't call your vehicle
Roche if you want to it's all up to you
but it will be your very own I wonder
how many of these cars are gonna vehicle
Roche now that you've mentioned it my
city is massive and that's like a point
we're really trying to make it's a huge
huge city and you kind of want people to
explore it by foot right you could just
walk right from point A to point B if
that's what you want or drive you could
but probably you would get pretty tired
because it's a pretty big place so you
will have to walk a lot so the thing is
you know we do not have loading screens
while exploring the city it's a
completely seamless place you can go you
know wherever you want and of course
Knight city is a very dense place so
there's lots to see on your way but the
thing is also you know
as with all things you want to give
players a choice so of course there's
the option to fast travel but the thing
is actually the way we're designing the
city we actually kind of feel like even
when you're playing it ourselves that
fast travel is often just when I play
the game I don't want a fast travel I
want to explore the city because we
actually tried to give you so many
interesting things so many places that
tell a story that look interesting where
you have something to do where you can
interact with things that just just
something new for you at every corner so
I personally don't fast travel a lot I
just drive my bike and I put on some
nice music and I have a good time but of
course you know it's possible and the
thing is also we actually have proper
city planners working here that actually
are planning out night city and you know
how the traffic would work in that city
and how it would actually make the most
sense how a city like that would
actually grow organically and you know
how it would flow how the traffic would
flow through there so it's actually
really interesting to also just have
that part of game development now as
part of you know cyberpunk 2077 because
this will be very important for how
people actually get to explore it
themselves to make the city feel alive
exactly yeah okay so in The Witcher
everybody who's played The Witcher knows
those question marks on the map those
points of interest you dreamt about them
when you were work you just thought
about them you can't walk past them so
what would be looking at first cyber
Punk you know what are those things that
are gonna be all-consuming so we are
probably not paying attention to the
main story we're gonna be like I've got
to go do that first and I can't go and
do this until I've done that one over
there what will we be finding so in
night city you actually really want to
tie it into the world so as an example
most districts have a so called fixer
like you might know from our gameplay
demo from a year ago there's Dexter
DeSean and people like this they you
know they can give you jobs that also
fit the specific district you're in so
if when you enter a district and you
know you're kind of known as a mercenary
who's doing certain things for money
fixers might contact you and they have
some jobs for you and then these jobs
you know as an example they can be
Street stories and they show up on your
map and you kind of you get them you
know you get an icon so you know okay
this is this kind of street story and we
always want to
put some interesting story to them
because after wild times we actually
founded a completely new team the open
world team which is actually creating
some amazing content to actually fill
this world with things that are
meaningful so you know we actually want
to make this that you can do many also
smaller things around the city but
they're actually all cool and unique in
their own way and one cool thing is also
of course they appear on your map
but the map in the game is actually
properly immersive it's that really
really cool looking point cloud version
of night city and you can see the tasks
from your fixer there but the cool thing
is actually because you know you're a
character in cyberpunk you're me and you
actually have this information so it's
not just the player seeing them it's
actually your character seeing them as
well because it's all part of the world
so we want to give you this full
immersion yeah is actually really really
cool for us that with the street stories
and all the other content we're
essentially sort of giving him like
almost our which are three side quest
treatment in the sense that even simple
tasks can be fun and exciting if we pack
them up in a cool story and route them
within the world right we can use these
Street stories to expand further on how
life in night city and the world of
cyberpunk in general works and sometimes
this might even be a better staging
ground than the the main story itself
right we're just like a let's see how
everyday life works in this kind of
aspect from this perspective in this
scenario and actually that's again like
first that's a lot of fun and it's a
very exciting process and I hope that
when players play it at the end that
they will actually find a sort of
enriching they experience because they
always kind of have this impression like
hey wow no matter where I go things I
actually worked out right it's never
just a simple sort of task of how you do
things like but there's always a reason
there's always an understanding of why
you're doing things and even in those
food scenarios where it might seem a bit
more you know oblivious you'll usually
find that you know there's more to it
than meets the eye
yeah and one interesting thing about
those three stories is also that you
know our main stories of course your own
personal journey through night city but
a street stories are actually because
you know you play a mercenary who's
trying to carve their way through the
city this
is actually your job so this is actually
the role you now inhabit in this city so
actually you're part of that system
through these three stories and through
working with fixers so it's actually
this whole different way of playing you
know the game and feeling immersed in
the city can't wait to lose my laughter
so in the deep dive we can see that the
character has three sort of origins that
we can pick I mean what are they and
they actually affect the gameplay oh
okay you're like yeah okay I'll go into
my 15 minute answer okay so we actually
call them life paths and those are the
origin stories that player can pick and
it's actually three of them so you can
be a Street deep it can be a nomad or
you can be a corporal now each of them
actually defines the beginning of the
story for the players so you start in a
completely different way than other life
paths and you are slowly introduced into
that story you know at different people
you're in a completely different place
in life you're in a different place in
night City and your story slowly you
know you get involved into that whole
thing with chip and Johnny Silver Hand
and eventually you know you Erlander but
you actually start off being a
completely different person now what is
important with that is we actually take
that through the whole game and you as a
player you can actually associate
yourself with like nomads you can
associate yourself with a corporate
people or you can be a part of the
streets and it's really up to you you
know what path you want to pick through
the main story and with our best in a
quest team to like support all those
like three I would say main ways to go
through this story and of course player
can like mix and match any time you know
anyway he really wants she really wants
but it's something that we take from the
very beginning till the very end and
what's important there is when you're in
the scenes with the characters so when
you are discussing things you can
actually use those things so if you're a
corporate and you know how the
corporation's work you know whether
there are no methods you know what's the
deal with them you actually can use this
knowledge and sometimes get something
more you can actually unlock side
branches in the dialogues and you can
look
branches in the whole quest sometimes
and this is a bit exciting I would say
it's something like the way how we are
we to make sure that the player can
roleplay their character you know to
become that that person and in the demo
that we have we have shown in recording
you can you can see you know this this
moment when you choose you know that
character that you're you are becoming
later in the characters that you are
meeting in the main story they are also
representing those different groups you
know so in the first demo a year ago we
have shown Meredith out you know a
person you know she is a high-class
corporate woman from a mealy texture
there's a lot of power also a lot of
responsibility and you are on her way
and you can see you know how that
interaction looks like so if you're when
you are from corporation maybe there's
something you can do a bit more with
hair you know and that goes also for
others you know for nomads and for for
street needs one of the nice things is
actually also that you know you're not
bound to stick let's say with the
corporates or with the street so as an
example I can give an example I started
as a street kid game and I always I know
I have my knowledge but then I play
through the story and I notice like I
kind of like these corporate characters
I like that life so you know I can just
you know betray the streets and snuggle
up with the corporates but you know this
is kind of the role playing freedom we
want to give but you know as always this
can also have consequences for you so
anyone who's a played the original table
top version of cyberpunk is used to the
idea of assigning attribute points to
create a character now in the deep dive
video we just saw we've got a little
glimpse of that screen you could see the
points of the different things so help
me understand how that works and how you
gain those points so as a player you
build your character at the beginning
assigning those attribute points and
then define like the core
characteristics of your character so how
much body strength you have or how much
reflexes you have or how cool you are
you know that's one of the interesting
stats that we have right but then as you
have those attributes you also have a
skills the skills define a bit more
interesting proficiencies for you as a
player what you can do and
for instance one of those skills is
assassination or the cold blood and
maybe I'll stick to the table to explain
a bit more so this is a skill that
allows the player to survive in a really
tough situation so at the moment you
know when you get a lot of damage then
the cold-blood skill kicks in
thanks to your cool stat it kicks in and
gives you a boost in damage and then as
a player you can you know survive and so
on but then you know using that skill so
you sort of like used by learning like
using that skill you can actually get
better pump up levels there and you can
get different perks now what's
interesting there you can actually give
completely different perks to the skill
that you have and here I think I could
use the example of the Athletics
attribute so the athletics is way for us
to move dead bodies so as a player you
can basically pick up the dead body that
you have just made well it's basically
killed pick it up and like stuff it into
the fridge or in a trash bin now as a
player you normally have slowed down
when you're moving around with the
bodies but if you have added special
perks to your at the athletic skill you
can now run with the dead body
so because you are more athletic you can
do that and those are like three levels
of complexity in our character in
building the character we have we have
their attributes you have the skills and
then you assign perks to it and those
three come together to allow you to
create your own amazing character that
you want to play it a lot of people
think that if maybe how cool you live
again it's all about the jacket you're
wearing but the cool fat is not a style
based is it
well you know this is cyberpunk so being
cool is of course very important but the
actual cool stat really means how cool
you are under pressure how much you have
control over your body so you know are
there people shooting at me and I'm
holding my gun like that probably not
very cool so this is you know this is
the kind of thing that cool actually
controls but of course you know if you
want to play a character it's actually
cool you have your choices right you can
you can wear your nice leather jacket
and of course you know like in real life
also depends on how you talk to people
and that's of course also the choice of
you as a player he just might freak out
on the gun
cool on the surface but that's so much
so in the deep dive we saw a quick clip
of the inventory screen it looks like a
proper old-school RPG screen you know
with the little blocks of the system and
I know the community wants to share more
about what they can expect so tell us
more mouse oh I will now of course like
I always say is you know in Sarpong the
inventory screens of course where we
manage our items right but most
importantly instead of Fung it's where
we also manage our style and just as
Philip just touched on you know like
it's really important for us to be able
for you to be able to realize your
character and that of course comes in
the character creation but also the way
you dress your character right we're
pretty much aware that there is sort of
this in most RPGs there's this common
sort of disconnect between the stats on
an item and the looks while we can't go
into details here let's just say we're
aware of this sort of you know conflict
I guess of interest sometimes so we're
looking into how you would be able to
make a character still look cool despite
having the best stats of an item right
and just goes to show that that is
really important to us and of course you
know the whole role-playing aspect goes
even further because we'll we'll have
some customisation options not only for
the way you look like but also your guns
right and the inventory will of course
decide what kind of weaponry it is that
your character uses to kill people with
or or sneak into two different in basis
locations because of course it's also
why we mention cyber wear and all of
these little things brought together
again they've sort of allow you to
fulfill your you're sort of what he
calls character fantasy that's the word
I was looking for in the inventory yes
we're changing our clothes we want to
look super cool but what about fiber
where can we do anything with fiber from
the inventory screen oh yes so imagine
imagine you
screen right so if you see the player
there you have a slot so normally in
like let's say fantasy game you would
equip a armor right or you would equip I
don't know a lag piece or something like
right now here you can actually replace
that with a cyberware right so you can
get your legs replace to your cyber legs
right and those can you can give you the
different skills like let's say double
jump but then as a player you can
upgrade actually those and let's say
enhance them in a way that they give you
something special to it so for instance
you can actually make them jump in a way
they do not emit that much sound and
they become like a like a really stealth
too so because of that you can traverse
in a quiet way through the locations so
this is how you actually upgrade your
character if you just go over your body
and replace whatever you need and in the
Lord there are reproduction you have to
install those core pieces of Cybermen
like for instance the Raven control
system that allows you to control the
flat head but there are also other
pieces that you can do on your own and
on top of that as a player you can also
find pieces small pieces called shards
and those if you slot into your slot you
can actually they give you a power of a
given cyberware so you can try it out so
as a player you can experiment a bit you
know and see how it would be if I would
have installed you know some special
pieces of cyberware in my body and that
allows the player to you know to see
stuff to figure it out to build their
character the way they want okay so we
know we can equip some of our cybernetic
enhancements in the inventory but like
where do we get them like how do we get
more enhancements alright there's
actually multiple ways of going about
that right the most obvious one is going
to a so-called Ripper doc and getting
new cyber are built in you or enhancing
the cyber wear that you have some of it
you will actually get through your as
you adventure through night city things
like the commercial item plan that we
have riots it's almost mandated on top
of you because it's sort of like a poor
gameplay mechanic to be able to scan
things and get additional information on
certain circumstances and
of course then we also have something
called a street cred system right so as
you progress throughout the game you
will also unlock more street cred for
your actions and that will enable you to
unlock more content in the game that
means you know more vendors will open up
to you all services welcomed people will
have heard of you and now more willing
to work with you
so there's actually multiple ways this
affects your experience and one of them
being you know like the cyber way that
you have access to so netrunner was
featured pretty heavily in the deep dive
but can you give us a little bit more
insight into some of the combat skills
or ability thing come with the idea of
building a net runner yeah so I think
using net training skills gives you lots
of let's say opportunities to be very
creative in how you play the game so I
can just give a few examples so we have
access points and access points are you
know in the world of cyberpunk they can
control all the different devices in the
area which of course is a net runner
it's pretty useful because you can hack
that access point and if you full of
successfully do that you can now use
quick hack so you can actually from a
distance take over different devices
like as an example a camera you can do
many different things with it look
through the camera and have a completely
different view or just you know turn it
off if it's in your way and of course
you know you can't take over a turret
and make it fight for you or you can do
many different things you know we also
tried to come up with nice custom things
so you know depending on where you are
let's say if you're in a gym or there's
some nice boxing robot of course you
know maybe you can do some fun things
with that so I think there's a net
runner it's always lots of fun to use
different things and as an example if I
would use lots of Medtronic stoves their
skills is also really useful to use lots
of cool skills that make me really good
at stealth so I'm you know really under
control so netrunner can be really good
at you know also using distractions like
if there's a vending machine just make
it spit out some drinks and then of
course you know might some people might
look after that but the thing is a net
runner isn't you know just a stealth
character there's also cool aggressive
net running abilities because you know
we always want to give you the choice of
how to play so we have here nanowire
cyberware which is really good at
hacking enemies from a distance and then
actually taking over there
we're so you know most people in this
world have cyber in their body so just
like access points very good times for
net runners so you can then control that
cyber where and also do some nice things
like you know as an example hack
someone's cyber where in their hand and
make them do some things they might not
want to have happen to them but the
thing is also the nanowire of course
it's a wire it's nano it's very you know
sharp so you can also use it as a weapon
or as a whip and you know the netrunner
can be very effective and using his
skills in combat as well so it's all
just you know your choice as a player
what about let's say this all sounds
amazing let's say you want to do
slightly non-lethal because in the deep
dive we did so with scratch sasquatch at
the end there was an option you know do
you want to put our misery or do you
want to let her live so how do people
play like a non-lethal playthrough can
you know can you build a class to help
you do that
mm-hmm so that's basically a choice we
maybe really set ok cyberpunk it is a
very violent world but you're a
role-playing your character you can
choose to play the whole game without
killing a single person and of course
you know we're always saying this should
also have an effect on the stories or
certain characters you know in a quest
might ask you you know yeah please do
this thing for me but you know don't
don't make too much trouble and of
course you know you don't get a game
over if you do a thing that the
character doesn't wanna so but the story
will react to it and we want to give you
that choice but of course you know not
only the netrunner is able to do
non-lethal playthrough every player
however you want to skill your character
you're able to do it somehow but of
course it also depends you know where
you are let's say if you're in some
random ruin that doesn't have lots of
met running abilities of course the
netrunner still has ways to do it but
you know he might not be able to use all
of his net running skills but another
player who has skilled different ways
now has a different experience but you
know it can happen vice versa but what
we always want to say you can finish the
whole game you can finish the quests
without killing a single person
sometimes you just have to also you know
think about it because the thing is
night city isn't a very peaceful place
so you can never play like a full
pacifist who's never engaging in any
kind of combat because you know people
will attack you sometimes but you can
choose to
not kill them because you know like in
real life sometimes if there's attacks
you don't immediately kill everyone you
can solve situations in different ways
yeah all right one thing I'd actually
like to add to that is that we're trying
really hard to not actually punish
players for the playstyle they chose to
do right whether is that you're playing
a lethal or non-lethal or you know like
more aggressive versus a more subtle
kind of approach and while NPCs might
sort of have certain wishes for you how
to approach this situation it will never
outright punish you for not you know
sort of doing their wishes because we
really want to give players as much
freedom as possible and you know taking
punishing the players for certain
actions like that
which is basically them choosing to play
that character would directly contradict
this kind of idea that we're trying to
set up in terms of role playing fantasy
nothing worse and like accidentally
flipping on the trigger like I didn't
mean to kill him and then everything and
as an example you can also see a
sasquatch that we show in our demo it's
a really intense fight but actually if
you choose you can subvert that fight
you can maybe just you know sneak around
her and find a different solution and
then maybe you know of course you can
get a consequence out of that because
now Sasquatch is still alive so you know
the story is already different so I
think this opens up many different
opportunities just not just for the
gameplay but also for us as storytellers
let's tell us a little bit more about
the solo builds because that was another
build from in the deep dive what kind of
skills of that give someone then as
opposed to never I think that the most
typical like solo fantasies that that
our players have is to be a strong so
learn to be fast solo so being like
different like I would say so but you
can also build any type of hair or
hybrid you want but the strong one is
the person who can lean on like shove
people into the trash bins and so on
carry bodies run with them but you can
also like pick up the heavy guns you
know mounted to death to the turret and
like use it against you know their
opponents like we have we have shown
that in the recording for a moment you
know when when V is like just you know
like killing everything on her way with
this very heavy
gun you of course cannot like take it to
your inventor and run around with
everything with it everywhere but this
is the only like I would see build that
allows you to do that right so this is
very very special however either like as
a fast solo you have access to lots of
different traversing skills so as an
expressive means of exploration you can
for instance do the double jump and
access places that you would not have
otherwise right you can also you know
like slide around with your katana or
like slide around using nanowire that we
have also shown so you can be built in a
completely in a completely different
ways built based on the stats that we
have picked as a person it sounds really
really cool I'm just gonna run in I
think and just punch everything until I
get what I want which is also like real
life yeah this game is so close to
realize incredible actually literally
happens every day so you know we've
talked about netrunner
and solo and we've shown both of them in
our deep dive but that's not just it
right like there are other bills so so
maybe tell us about Teddy yeah um so
generally how we approach this kind of
stuff is we've sort of thought we're
thinking of three sort of main
archetypes of how you can play the game
that would be the net runner place to
write the solo play style which has
puzzles that sort of branches into sort
of more agile fast solo and the more
brutish strong solo character and then
there's the last one which is the techy
again it's just important for us to say
that these are just archetypes that you
know help us think about how players
might approach any kind of situation but
of course you'll be able to create any
kind of hybrid and just pick the skills
that you like in between and the techie
you know it's sort of a more technically
affiliated play style right whereas the
netrunner
is the one that sort of manipulates
devices are active by it by hacking
networks and taking over control the
techie is actually the one that sort of
dabbles with the hardware itself and
cables and and whatever drives machinery
all that stuff and
to add on top of that we're actually
layering our little buddy called flat
hat and he is what we call a spider bot
a kind of very sophisticated piece of
military hardware that the player will
be able to use when he chooses to to you
know invest into the techy playstyle and
cycle is an interesting one because he's
pretty like basically like this
autonomous robot that listens to your
commands and you can mostly send out
flat head to do certain things for you
right you might be able to send them out
to manipulate certain devices right
there might be I don't know
smoke with an example here um there is
some sort of like broken broken lamp or
something or like a broken gadget you
can see it with your scanner right and
you might actually send flat hat to do a
little bit of tweaking there to make
that object fall down onto an enemy
right or or other examples would be to
use for her to you know directly engage
with enemies there's a certain
customization options that might be tied
to to a buddy robot and I hope actually
players will forget like oddly attached
to their little robot buddy right and
and again this is like a whole sort of
layer and another layer of how you might
play the game and as I said earlier with
us thinking of the archetypes it is like
one of the possible many many possible
ways of how to play the game and we're
trying to add as many tools as we can
for all three of these archetypes to
really sort of be able to manipulate the
game world and and feel like yeah this
this world you know if I look around I
see opportunities that suit me you know
you've maybe fantasizing to play as a
sort of terminator kind of character
right we have our scanner you look
around see opportunities and you sees
them and that
and how you see them and what
opportunities arise where it really just
depends on what kind of character you're
playing and what skills you have
invested in okay so we all stand flat
heads we know that flat head is
everything but also let's talk about
actual weapons let's talk about guns
what can we expect we saw a few we saw
the military being ripped out use as a
machine gun
we saw the nanowires but tell us a
little bit more so our guns are divided
into three like main categories right
there is a there are smart guns that we
have shown in a previous demo like a
year ago so basically they shoot like
homing bullets they're following target
there are also tech weapons and the tech
weapons are those that have like
additional capabilities to them that
they for instance can pierce covers and
there are also power weapons and power
weapons are mainly focused on being a
street grid a grid weapon so they
basically have additional skills and
capabilities connected to the fact that
we worked in some ways so for instance
those are like bursting shotguns and
things like that and we have put plenty
of work to making sure that the weapons
feel well and they have their weight and
there's lots of really cool examples
that I can give here for instance you
know there is a handgun that as you use
it it actually speeds up the bullets
slowly and and longer you use it faster
the bullets become so they can do more
more things and they can do more damage
that there is for instance like a class
of the weapons for a handgun that is
that has been created by Russian company
to fight cyborgs and that weapon like is
able to heat up the bullet to the point
that the bullet becomes almost like a
melted plastic and is done for instance
we can shoot off you know cyborgs arms
and so on so oh there's always like a
small piece of story you know wrapped up
around the weapon you know what what
that weapon does and what's interesting
here I think is that you can also use
like a second firing mode for a weapon
and not all weapons have them but some
of them if you use them in a specific
way let's say a tech rifle that we have
shown in a previous demo when you like
when you use it in
it changes its way it like collapses
together and then it allows you to
pierce up the covers and shoot through
the walls and shoot the enemies like
that or you can you know bounce bullets
of the walls right using the ricochet
so it although we try to always put
enough depth into the gun for instance I
like literally today I have seen like
awesome shotgun that has eight barrels
and there shoots them in the same time
and it has like a actually our I think
that players will love our gunplay
especially the way how the guns look and
how they feel when you should them I'm
sorry fired that that's yeah
shotguns they're my favorite eight-balls
even better I think also something
really cool to add to this is that you
know as you are a touched on it like all
these companies these gun manufacturers
and all stuff they actually I mean a lot
of it comes from the actual law right
but we're also making sure that you know
there's a history to everything that
includes the the brands and ads that we
haven't get in the game we actually have
like a whole team dedicated to just that
kind of stuff and again it's sort of is
in line with our philosophy to make sure
that everything is rooted in the world
has its reason why it is there has its
history I think that's really sort of
like the secret ingredient to make like
a really believable world that when the
player actually goes in that they have
this impression like yeah this place
exists right this feels alive and I
think that will make just the fact of
simply walking through night city like a
really really cool experience well so
actually one of the cool things we also
have is we have lots of different melee
weapons and you know it starts by you
know very spontaneous one so let's say
you find a broken bottle and you just
use it or you find a knife on the ground
and you can use it to fight Bailey or
you can as an example throw it but you
can also specialize in melee weapons
because as we said earlier maybe you
want to play as a cyber ninja and of
course as a cyber ninja there's many
different katanas that you can actually
also specialize and getting really good
at them and there's even cyber where for
melee like the gorilla fists that can
also be used to you know be really
strong and open doors but you know if
you're really strong you can also hit
people with it but the cool thing is
also you
your melee weapons together with special
cellular so as an example my favorites
eyewear that I always like to use is to
send Davis time and essentially it slows
down time for you because your reflexes
get boosted so now you have superhuman
reflexes and the way we show it is of
course time slowing down for you as a
player so it mentioned you have your
katana and you just go into a slide and
then you can aim and like just go
through and it actually feels really
cool like you feel like you have super
control but actually you can also see as
an example in the demo how it feels like
to be in the receiving end of cyber wear
like that so the animals have reflex
boosting cyber wear as well so actually
sometimes when they're coming to work so
in melee they sip around really fast
that is exactly and this is how it
actually feels for enemies when you have
your you know slow-mo this is how they
see you moving around so it can be
pretty scary to also find someone who
uses the same cyber where you use what
about you to them what about what are
your favorite five ways that you've seen
so far that you can talk about so far
before you get me in trouble oh I think
that that at least for me I think those
those are gonna be mounted lights I
think that's that's the best one we have
shown how it looks for the player how it
feels when you use them you know the way
you can chop off heads and so on it's
something of a boy very poetic I would
say yeah in another cyber where I think
that I would like it's more story later
than mr. stud I will let our players to
figure what it does for those who know
the lore for me Phil already took it
away by by taking the strong arms
earlier and the sunder is done so bit of
a greedy dude over there no but so I
guess technically this cyber deck is a
side piece of cyber well right that's
the one that actually allows you to to
breach Internet whereas take over
control and you know use all that the
hacking magic on all kinds of enemies
right like in the in the gameplay we
show how you can not only manipulate
this training robot but you can also
manipulate devices that you might not
think are necessarily hackable like the
the
benchpress that
we showed there and it'll goes even
further than that right if you combine
that with like for example nanowires but
also you can do it from from closer up
you can actually breach into like a
squads internal network by hacking
directly into the personal links of of
enemies and once you're in the squad
Network you can actually use what we
call daemon software and to essentially
quick hack the cyber where that is
attached to people's bodies right so
imagine a scenario where you know you're
in it runner kind of character you're
sneaking through but then things get hot
right so now you find yourself in a
combat situation
luckily of course you come prepared you
already foresaw that things might might
go wrong because you're a skilled net
runner after all so you already breached
into the squad's internal network now
these enemies start swarming you and
what do you do of course you start using
your scanner and you look at these guys
and you realize hey I breached the
security so I can now upload my virus
software into these guys to make them do
things that they don't necessarily want
you might tack their cybernetic hand to
force them to pull the pin on a grenade
they have at their you know grenade belt
I'm setting him to fiery and explosive
but spectacularly looking death now
totally we also have one that you can
actually use to basically make enemies
finish themselves off right to shut
themselves down and it's actually cool
because you sort of see them struggling
with their hand as well so it's like you
really sells the fantasy of what you're
doing right and you're basically
becoming this cybernetic God as soon as
you take over a network and it really is
something that you know feels so
different from the other play styles
that we have and and I really like the
sort of level of variety that we offer
players and when it comes I think that
ultimately and pardon me for being a bit
buzzed worthy about this but like this
will really make each playthrough very
unique to players right not only the way
you play it the way you interact with
the world
the way you talk to people all that kind
of stuff like you if you look at all the
little choices that accumulate through
the game no place where we'll basically
be like another and and inherently they
will also feel very differently
depending on what kind of you know
character you you want to play and I
guess that would be the more less
obvious one because as a net runner
you'll always be sort of having your
cybertek because otherwise you could not
be a net runner and then I think I've
mentioned before in a nother video
sources I really really like our
nanowires which go hand-in-hand sort of
with this net running player I guess you
can see where my preferences personal
preferences lie don't worry does not
affect my designs
I try to be balanced but you know like
whereas the regular netrunner can sort
of reach into a squat network by sort of
taking an enemy out and having an extra
option to breach into into their Sports
Network the nanowires actually allow you
to do this from a distance or from a
safe spot right and they can also be
used to slice people into bite-sized
pieces so again as Philip said much
earlier if I remember correctly we've
been doing this for a bit there is
actually you know no playstyle that is
sort of meant to be played in a certain
way right we don't go okay the hacker
kind of character he's the stealthy guy
he needs to operate from the shadows
whereas the the solo type he's the one
that you know just goes out and shoots
everyone know you can actually still
within these play styles choose how you
play the the kind of character lethal
non-lethal stealthy and non stealthy and
we just give you the tools in all place
else to do whatever you want with it
right so if you want to be a combat
netrunner if you will that likes to use
gunfire and you know making people blow
themselves up sure go do that but you
can also do it in a stealthy approach it
really lies in the players hands so
let's say I've got my eight bowel
shotgun
it's my bet it's my favorite gun I love
it what can I do to it can I customize
it is it multiple are there any options
for you know really making something
special than one of a kind so I think we
can say that there are like two major
ways what you can do how you can
customize your guns one way is
customizing the visuals and those are
different skins and like paint overs
paint jobs that they can have on your
gun just to make sure that you know when
you're a cupid that your rifle is pink
or or purple you know if you really want
it but then there's the second way how
you can customize it it's a different
sort of attachments that you can have
you can have silencers you know you can
have like a sniper rifle zoom on the gun
you also can boost up the stats of the
given weapon so in that way you can
basically make it more efficient so you
can make it wanna to look the way you
want and you can make it the shoot you
it was I think mozzie mention is the
fall that also changes the animation
right if it progresses you can change
the way it looks as you reload and
things like that yeah so basically the
the more you use your guns who figure is
the better you become at shooting them
right you might start as in complete
amateur like I would be with shooting a
gun yeah I'm not a very good shot and
the the the better you become with it
you know that actually affects your way
of handling a gun so you know your like
your crosshair might become smaller and
indicating that your your accuracy
increases ever so slightly and that will
also sort of influence the the way your
your animation looks like your reload
speed will be faster and all that time
so you actually get this the sense of
progression and your character evolving
as you play the game and yeah I think
that's pretty special sort of experience
you combine it with the way you know
that you can customize your guns amount
and kind of really have this feeling
that yeah this is my signature gun right
and I'm really good with it right guys
thank you so much I know there is one
thing we haven't talked about from the
demo now it's a little bit more about
the gangs we spoke with a voodoo boys a
bit but we haven't even really spoke
about the animals and I know you guys
know everything about Psychopaths I
thought I'd actually throw out two maybe
the Godfather himself so I clap with
Mike pom Smith at Gamescom to ask him
who are the Voodoo boys and who are the
animals
I might even white paws Smith and I'm
the guy who killed your cyberpunk
characters and today I'm gonna talk to
you about two very important things I'm
gonna talk to you about animals and i'ma
talk about voodoo boys so let's say the
Buddha boys what I created them many
many years ago I was looking at kind of
a really interesting idea which is what
we were now called cultural
appropriation what happens when somebody
comes in and tried to adopt a culture
that they know little or nothing about
and does it really badly but one of the
great things about having a few years is
that you get a chance to do some reduce
and one of the best ones is what we have
with Buddha boys now the Voodoo boys in
2077 are really Buddha boys they
inherited the name but it was sort of a
natural fit they were coming from Haiti
and a diminished Dominican Republic and
they were the real thing and they
managed to take a lot of the elements of
their original culture and meld it into
the world of 2077 bring that cyberpunk
vibe into a very old and respected
culture so they're a gang but they're
not really they're more of a cultural
phenomenon they're more a way of
cultural explanations
and I think it's really cool because it
shows us a side of the cyberpunk future
that we normally would see on the other
hand there the animals way way back in
my dark dank past I used to lift don't
anymore but I used to and I would see
guys like the animals in the gym I went
to guys who lived to get strong and get
really strong and get really strong the
animals are like those guys they're in
it to basically build themselves up and
become the Tigers of their particular
urban jungle they want to be big they
want to be bad and they want you to fear
them just because they exist and you
know it's really easy to fear a guy who
blots out the Sun when he walks by you
but the animals are very simple they
haven't eat those get big lift get
strong lift
so unlike the Buddha boys who have a
culture the animals have a think and
contrasting that is interesting because
in 2077 you get a chance to see that not
every gang is the same as every other
gang and what motivates them depends on
the people you meet on the street check
it out
this Mike Fossum is saying I'm still
here to feel your startup here we hope
you enjoyed our deep dive into cyberpunk
2077 now don't forget you can join us on
Twitter Facebook forums and even join us
on this core to make sure you stay up to
date on all of our news cyberpunk 2077
is launching April 16th 2020 and is
available for pre-order now on behalf of
everybody working on cyberpunk and here
at CD Projekt RED we thank you for
watching your ongoing support and we
can't wait for you to explore night city
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]